60 times the square root of 3y is correct. That's amazing if you figured this
one out, I know it was tough. Now there are a lot of ways to simplify this
radical, I'm going to show you the quickest way. We start by splitting 108 into
36 times 3, 36 is the largest perfect square that goes into 108. First 75 we'll
split it up into 25 times 3. Now we can apply the product rule and split up
this radical into two separate radicals. The square root of 36 times the square
root of 3y. We do the same thing for this radical. This allows us to take the
square root of 36 which is 6. and the square root of 25, which equals 5. We
know 5 times 6 equals 30, and 6 times 5 also equals 30. We have two like
radicals, since they're both the square root of 3y, and we add 30 and 30 to get
our final answer, 60 times the square root of 3y.